coming up on today's vlog an explanation
as to why my hair keeps changing color
which I promise will be more interesting
that it sounds like it's gonna be and a
sneaky peek at my brand-new secret
project but first I want to talk about
my holiday this year on my summer
holiday Emily and I went to Greece our
story begins in Athens which we went in
for very long but we were there just
long enough to do a bit of a
whistle-stop tour of some of the ruins
here we have the temple of olympian zeus
wow this thing is really impressive I
really wish they'd finish it though I
think it would be really great they just
throw in a bit more effort we also hit
up the Panathenaic Stadium
pretty sure I got that one right it's
sir chill out buddy watching what you
doing get down thank you very much it's
not a real in itself but it is built on
the site of an ancient Greek Stadium and
it's also the place where the first ever
modern Olympics were held most amazing
thing about being here I think is the
privilege to see some real Olympians in
action down there pretty special I
couldn't however figure out why this
statue with two heads had a willy stuck
on it though that was not included in
the audio guide for some reason our
final destination in Athens was the our
cropper lists which is essentially a
little city's worth of ruins the main
feature being the Parthian and I'm not
good at the Greek words sorry we were
there a bit offseason which meant they
were doing some renovations on the ruins
which was weird because I knew that the
buildings were thousands of years old
but it did make them look like they
still hadn't finished them yet
after Athens we ventured off into the
Mediterranean Sea on a ferry that would
take us to our next destination in a
mere 13 hours yep nothing really
happened on the ferry but I was on it
for a very long time and I did take a
lot of footage on it because I was on
there for so long so I am now talking to
fill in the time over which I will put
lots of shots from the ferry so that I
don't feel like my time with the ferry
was wasted their weekend and finally we
arrived at the island of Falak and rose
at sunset which made it look like
something out of Jurassic Park it's kind
of awesome going to Falak Andros was
basically our attempt at getting away
from it all and it definitely did that
like it was actually much quieter there
than either of us thought it was gonna
be
Nero Vaska drive while we were there and
there was only one bus on the entire
island so we did do a lot of walking to
start off with I did actually find it
quite scary because I just didn't
realize quite how
I was on the convenience of living in a
place like London but after a day also I
did get used to it and it did pretty
quickly become my favorite part of the
trip just because just the quiet I just
I really like the quiet slide note does
anybody know what this flower is because
pretty much everywhere we went in Greece
Emily was walking around smelling a
smell and eventually as you discovered
that the smelling question was coming
out of this flower but we do not know
what the flower is so please help
because we need to have the flower a
final destination on the trip was the
island of Santorini pictured here as
Santorini our accommodation is basically
on the side of a cliff so there are a
lot of steps Greek people must have
prayed but apparently it was offseason
but they were an inordinately which I
would complain about more but I was also
one of them so can't really do that
could I I guess the most obvious example
of the Torosidis was when we went to go
and see the sunset which was apparently
the best thing you could do on the
island and it was incredibly beautiful
and there were also a lot of other
people who wanted to see it most of the
time we just sort of chilled out on
Santorini but there was that one day
when we went on a pirate ship to go
visit a volcano so let's chill we hiked
up to the top of the central island in
Santorini which has only been recently
created by the volcano and I will admit
that the whole time we were hiking up
there I did think that we were on our
way to see an actual volcano crater with
some lava turns out the actual volcano
is very very deep underground so instead
we saw some steam which was still pretty
cool less dramatic though and finally we
kept off our trip by taking our pirate
ship to go and see that sunset one more
time and it was cloudy is probably some
metaphor for life in there somewhere but
I can't be able to figure out what it is
that's what I did some holiday so the
reason my hair keeps on changing colour
over the course of that video is because
I'm in the video game and I probably
need to explain that a bit more deeply I
made a video game didn't tell you about
that it's called volume it comes out
this summer oh that's exciting and
basically Mike the guy who's making the
game asked me if I'd like to be in a
live-action trailer to help promote the
game and the characters hair was black
so I dyed my hair black probably could
have picked a better way to promote your
game Mike than just talking about my
hair there we go and last but not least
the secret projects oh good lord
it has its own YouTube channel which
should give you a vague hint as to what
it might be and on that YouTube channel
is a little
and I'll link to it here I am suddenly
incredibly nervous about the secret
project that's it for today go goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching if you would like to
see my previous video you are in luck
the link is just over there and if you
would like to see the teaser I don't
know why you didn't click on it earlier
but I'm hoping you'll click on it this
time it's right over there
teaser for the new secret project
special thanks to gideon for making this
video incredibly easy to film by staying
quiet the whole time also special thanks
to Emily for organizing the whole Greece
trip and for also sticking up Chris
Pratt on my wall because I was
complaining about the fact that this
wall was a bit blank that I came
downstairs one day and that was there
and I just left it because he's great in
it and now I will go to bed because
although it looks like daytime it is
actually 10 p.m. good bye